Otra revelación más importante que sale a la luz
es lo trivial de las propias arrogancia y vergüenza.
Comprender hasta qué punto tu sentido del ridículo
te impide aprovechar las oportunidades
debería permitir a la gente tomar riesgos que no tomarían.
Solo somos un instante en la línea temporal del universo.
Actúen como tal.
Las ideas que hoy les presento me fueron infundidas
por alguna que otra circunstancia desafortunada,
pero están latentes en la vida de quien quiera aprovecharse de ellas.
Si entendemos que todos tenemos debilidades
y somos honestos sobre estas
aprenderemos cómo sacarles partido al máximo.
Ya sea subir a una acera, presentar un informe de ventas
o la incapacidad de gestionar nuestro dinero de forma eficiente,
estoy mirando a ese tipo ...
(Risas)
Permanece la capacidad de aprender, de adaptarse
e incluso la de cambiar la respuesta a las dificultades.
La adversidad es positiva
y tiene el potencial de hacerte más fuerte.
Y, en última instancia,
puedes espantar a los niños si pareces un pirata.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y vítores)